- Hi, I'm Shelby Harris.
I'm here with Bleacher
Report, and I'm playing
"Start, Bench, Cut."
I'm going to be given a
topic, and I'm gonna have to
start one, bench one and cut one.
So I'mma start "Remember the Titans."
That's a easy one, one of my favorite ones,
and then I'mma bench "Friday Night Lights."
And considering I've never
seen "Rudy," I'm gonna cut it.
(Laughing)
Never seen Rudy before.
One of my favorite scenes, you know,
when the linebacker got hurt.
When how the team like rallied behind him,
that just, it shows the true
meaning of being on a team.
And that just...
it's really special.
All right, let's go...
I'mma start telepathy. I think
that's——that's huge.
And that'd be cool, like,
to be able to read minds.
That'd be awesome.
I would have to bench
super speed
cuz I'm obviously a
big defensive lineman.
I'm not the fastest guy in the world.
But then I just I would
cut superhuman strength.
I think that you can live with
the other two without the third.
Always wanted to know what Von is thinking
cuz I'm telling you that man,
he's a different type of man.
So, you know, he must
have some crazy thoughts.
All right, I gotta start Serena Williams.
I feel like, you know, man or
woman she's one of the best
athletes out there, just what
she did after having a child
and coming back and dominating
the sport again is, you know,
gotta commend her.
I'd have to bench Tiger Woods.
I really feel like, you know, coming back
after that whole controversy
and with his knees and
backs and everything,
just coming back and winning
the Masters that one time.
That was just a huge moment, and you know,
I just feel like that was special.
And then, you know, unfortunately,
you gotta cut Tom Brady.
And it makes it easier
cuz he's a football player.
But honestly just,
you know, I just feel like the
feats of those other two are just——
I look at those differently
just cuz I play football.
But I feel like those
are just so remarkable
in what they've done.
Oh, that easy. OK, wings I'm starting.
I love wings.
I'm a big wing guy, and
then I'mma bench pizza.
And then I don't even think
I've ever had seven-layer dip
to be honest.
It sounds tasty. It sounds like something
I would get at Taco Bell.
But, you know, honestly, yeah
I love my wings. I love pizza.
And, you know, seven-layer dip
has just gotta go.
So if we're talking like spicy
wings, I like blue cheese.
You know, the buffalos,
the Caribbean jerks, the
mango habaneros, those.
But if you're talking,
you know, garlic parmesan,
you gotta go ranch.
OK...
I gotta start "Get Rich or Die Tryin'."
I feel like that, I could play
that one from start to finish,
and nothing but heat right
there, I'm telling you.
And then I'mma have to
bench "Tha Carter III."
I really, you know, I
remember growing up on that,
that went hard. But
then, you know, I'mma have
unfortunately have to cut "The Blueprint."
I'm not really the biggest
Jay-Z fan, you know,
but I still like some
of the songs on there,
but definitely not as
much as the other two.
All right, well, you know I feel like
you gotta start Beyoncé.
I feel like that was a great performance.
I enjoy Beyoncé, and my wife enjoys Beyoncé.
so we enjoy, we enjoy Beyoncé.
You know, I'm gonna have
to bench Janet Jackson
cuz that was a epic
performance.
You know, just that something
that everyone's been talking
about for 10 years plus,
you know, so that was
huge. And then, you know,
unfortunately, you gotta cut Katy Perry.
I love Katy Perry. I think
she's a great, you know,
singer and performer but
just those other two
just are remarkable.
I'm Shelby Harris, and I just
played "Start, Bench, Cut."